[Music]
when it comes to Native Americans our
country has a long-standing tradition
now you might think it's Thanksgiving
but it's not it's Erasure don't know
what I mean well let me explain in a
segment called how did we get here
November is National Native American
Heritage Month a time to celebrate the
rich culture of the first people of this
land but sadly since the founding of our
country the U.S government has been
working harder than a toddler with an
Etch A Sketch to try to erase it and
like Gargamel trying to catch a Smurf
they have cooked up about a million evil
schemes to do it but we never learned
this stuff in school so before we get
inundated with Happy Thanksgiving
imagery this month let's talk about it
and to start let's visit the 1860s but
not really because I don't want to wear
17 skirts at once
in the 1860s the U.S government took
native kids from their families and
placed them in boarding schools and not
one of those fun boarding schools where
you get good advice from Mrs Garrett
these boarding schools were created for
the sole purpose of making native kids
whiter or as the government described it
to help native kids assimilate which is
insane they didn't need to assimilate to
America because they were here first
that's like a burglar breaking into your
house and sending you off to burglar
school to make you more burglary
the U.S government sent tens of
thousands of native children to these
boarding schools with the express
purpose of making them less native the
schools were incredibly abusive and
thousands of kids died in them and were
then buried in unmarked Graves some of
which are still being discovered today
the schools were also an effort at land
acquisition now stay with me
wild native kids were in boarding
schools they were discouraged from
continuing their agricultural practices
so native people started relying more on
Goods they purchased from the government
on credit and when these folks fell into
debt they gave up their land as payment
it's a horrible part of our nation's
history and you can learn more about it
in the director's cut of A Charlie Brown
Thanksgiving
now let's visit the World War II era but
not really because I don't want to wear
a bathing suit with a belt now
just what is it holding up despite every
everything that you
despite everything the US had done to
Native people they were actually the
first to step up and fight on the
nation's behalf in World War II in some
tribes as many as 70 percent of eligible
men served which is amazing because
usually when you hear a sentence start
with 70 percent of men it ends with
think they could beat Serena Williams at
tennis
But after those men bravely served they
came back to find the reservations they
lived on had been devastated and here's
the worst part that was part of the plan
see the government wanted to get Native
Americans off the reservations first
because they were still into the
assimilation thing and second so then
they could steal the land these people
are worse than Gargamel this is some
Skeletor level [ __ ]
the government passed something called
the Indian relocation Act of 1956 which
among other things dissolved Federal
funding for reservations schools
hospitals and basic Services it's truly
insane it's like when your landlord
refuses to fix your bathtub to force you
to move out except your landlord is the
US government and the bathtub is
everything you need to stay alive and
just when you think it can't get worse
it does which by the way is the official
slogan of American history
thank you
because around the same time the US
government created something called a
termination policy that's where they
gave up the game entirely they didn't
just stop paying for stuff they said hey
tribes you're not tribes anymore
literally between 1953 and 1964
109 tribes were terminated that means
that 2.5 million Acres of trust land was
removed from protected status and 12 000
Native Americans lost tribal affiliation
honestly it's hard to talk about it's
one of those things that you wish you
never found out like the fact that Buzz
Aldrin peed his pants on the moon
that is true he admits it and I can't
unknow it
that was the very last time the U.S
tried to erase native culture just
kidding as we said before
us when you think it can't get worse it
does so let's visit 2022 but not really
because I don't want to wear boyfriend
jeans
a boyfriend they don't do laundry why
would I want to wear his dirty ass jeans
this week the Supreme Court heard
arguments in Holland versus brackeen a
case about a white couple who are
challenging a current U.S law called the
Indian Child Welfare act that law says
that in order to preserve native culture
we should Place native children who are
up for adoption with Native parents
whenever possible and let me tell you we
need this law because in the 60s and 70s
25 to 35 percent of all Native children
had been separated from their families
and put into foster care or adopted and
90 percent were placed in non-indian
homes now this law was put into place to
stop that well the white couple in
Holland versus brackeen is basically
saying that that law is Reverse Racism
but if Reverse Racism were a thing then
they wouldn't lock up black hair care
products at Walgreens they'd lock up
sunscreen
and skinny girl margaritas
so this case is actually about a lot
more than that saying this case is about
adoption is like saying When Harry Met
Sally Is about orgasms but that's part
of it but it's not the whole picture
Okay so see it turns out the lawyers
representing the couple in this case
also represent fossil fuel companies now
why would fossil fuel companies care
about an adoption case because and stay
with me again if you take away the
government's right to make special rules
for the tribes you could undermine
tribal sovereignty altogether and that
means that all those reservation lands
would be up for grabs and just like a
person who ate at Taco Bell that land is
full of oil and gas
so those companies will support anything
that could possibly get them that land
so now we've left Skeletor level and
entered Mr Burns level territory these
oil companies are trying to do what our
government has been trying to do since
its founding a race native people for
their own personal benefit and this
month the Supreme Court will decide if
they're going to let them do that so
this November let's celebrate native
history and culture and while we're
doing that let's also be honest about
our country's long history of trying to
erase it and let's commit to stopping
that cycle
and while we're at it let's also commit
to getting rid of boyfriend jeans this
has been how did we get here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]